und dann weiß nicht ob die mitgekommen
haben war am dienstag noch welttag der
pressefreiheit das ist eine optimale
gelegenheit mal daran zu erinnern dass
in london die auslieferung von julian
assange an die usa quasi vor der tür
steht ist nach dem neuesten urteil des
westminster magistrates' court lässt
sich das wohl nur noch durch die
innenministerin der regierung boris
johnson verhindern ich habe kein gutes
gefühl
seine auslieferung wäre wirklich ein
furchtbarer schlag für die
pressefreiheit denn nur zur erinnerung
assange drohen bis zu 175 jahre knast in
den usa weil er amerikanische
kriegsverbrechen unter anderem im irak
aufgedeckt hatte frage warum setzt sich
unsere ampel nicht viel lauter für den
man hier ein warum findet die
unmittelbar bevorstehende auslieferung
bei uns medial so gut wie gar nicht
statt ok zumindest für letzteres hat
dietmar wischmeyer eine plausible
erklärung
wischmeyer so buch der bekloppten und
bescheuerten die sache mit der songs ist
tatsächlich schlimm da müssten
eigentlich alice schwarzer und ihre
komischen schauspieler mal dringend
einen offenen brief schreiben machen sie
aber nicht und die deutschen medien
kennen auch warum weil sie voll
ausgelastet sind mit der
berichterstattung zu einem viel
schlimmeren fall um gottes willen ein
landsmann ist in britische
gefangenschaft geraten unser boris ein
klarer fall für schnappatmung rund um
die uhr breaking news und wir schauen
nach london meine damen und herren und
sehen hier in diesem moment ehrlich
gesagt und ich sagen bin ich ganz sicher
was wir da gerade sehen
ein haus ein bild tv moderator der gar
keine breaking news hat egal tatsache
ist ein deutscher sitzt in einem
haferschleim verseuchten britischen
kerker nur weil er sich angeblich nicht
an das britische insolvenzrecht gehalten
hat am mein gott was soll er das kennen
der mann ist gelernter ball verkloppt
und musste sich immer wieder gegen
verleumdung wären so wie damals als es
hieß er hätte in der besenkammer knick
knack obwohl unser kurzes miteinander
nicht immer besenkammer stattgefunden
hat sondern in der tat auf der treppe
oder eben zwischen den toiletten
ganz was anderes in einer
bedürfnisanstalt wird ja schon per
definition ein bedürfnis befriedigt
aber wenigstens stehen die deutschen
medien schulter an schulter mit unserem
helden und informieren die erschütterte
öffentlichkeit jetzt zwar nicht über
assange aber über die unfassbaren
zustände in denen ein boris becker seine
karriere abend verbringen muss essen auf
plastiktellern toilette in der zelle und
ja angeblich auch ratten in brauneberg
stellen um gemütlich das hier sind die
exklusiven bilder von boris beckers
neuem zuhause ex insassen berichten von
schreien und die zelle die ist gerade
mal 65 quadratmeter große trend das ist
ja einfach reinkommen es immer einfach
früher raus kommt aber wohl nur mit
hilfe eines anderen baumes des
amtierenden meisters aus downing street
number ten warum leiten wir somit becker
aber kaum mit assange ist ganz simpel
einer von beiden ist halt einer von uns
einer der sagt das und dass ich das ich
stolz deutscher zu bin
gibt es auch zu ich habe lange dieses
land verdreht mit dem schläger in der
hand und dem kopf voll nichts was den
sieg kosten könnte ein deutscher aus dem
lehrbuch 1 dürfen wir deshalb nie
vergessen mit boris becker wurde auch
ein teil von uns ins gefängnis geworfen
das logbuch der bekloppten und
bescheuerten
[Applaus]
so
aufnahme
hallo dies ist die automatische and cut
von oliver welke und der heute show
leider ist das video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres video
anschauen vielen dank so müsse jetzt für
immer reicher